in the comic book world she suffered
from breast cancer we're not sure that
she's gonna if we're gonna do a complete
lift of their whole storyline these
since they change all the way often to
each district they changed through the
shook and even when we ever sing
something like that when the Edit right
let's get real their storyline where
she's well Prince goes up or changes
into something else or Woody's dish
maybe she's fine so everything will
change we um you know I think that's a
really powerful part of the just the
book so I think it's really cool that
you know like she's fighting this thing
and yes she's like these two battles
going on so Chris Mallory loved it their
storyline
[Music]
how's it going everybody it's worn and
as you just saw in this video in this
interview with Taika Waititi who of
course directed thor ragnarok he also
played our favorite character Korg and
of course he is directing the upcoming
Thor love and thunder just told us that
he is considering doing a major
storyline from the comics with Jane
Foster and thort love and thunder now we
already know because it was announced at
San Diego comic-con that Natalie Portman
is going to be returning to the Thor
franchise reprising her role as Jane
Foster and of course the news was huge
not only because of her return but
because they also revealed that she is
going to be playing a version of Thor
and she's going to be able to lift me
own ear but now another surprise has
come out it seems like Taika Waititi
could be going with the breast cancer
element of Jane Foster storyline from
the comics quick reminder to subscribe
to my channel for your chance to win an
Xbox one or a ps4 and so you can stay up
to date on everything relating to the
MCU so everybody is kind of wondering
how Jane Foster is going to come back
and how she's going to be worthy to lift
Muni
what's her story going to be in Thor
love and thunder well as you just heard
Taika Waititi say in the interview he is
always liked the breast cancer element
of the Jane Foster storyline in the
comics as tyka said in the interview he
thinks it's a very powerful part of the
books he thinks it's really cool that
she's fighting breast cancer there's two
battles going on the Battle of becoming
Thor dealing with that mantle and all
the responsibilities that come with it
and the
battle with breast cancer he says he
loves that storyline and as of right now
it does seem like that is going to be a
part of Thor love and thunder although
he does say that things can change he
says that things can change during the
shoot and things can change during the
editing process as well so it seems like
right now he has decided on this
storyline but isn't a hundred percent
sure if he's going to leave it in the
movie but like he said this is a very
powerful storyline from the comics Jane
Foster does have breast cancer when she
picks up the mantle of Thor she wills
mule near and becomes the Mighty Thor
but this actually in turn ends up
killing her each time she wields me on
air and turns into Thor the
transformation process purges all of the
toxins from her body including the
chemotherapy treatment so unfortunately
her taking on the mantle of Thor and
wildung Muller makes her breast cancer
worse so it's a very emotional story
line and Taika Waititi has already
expressed in the past that he does like
the emotional aspect now in the comics
the reason why Jane Foster becomes Thor
is because Thor Odinson is deemed
unworthy and Jane Foster as it turns out
is worthy however when she became Thor
at first she didn't tell Thor Odinson he
had no idea was her so he went on
looking for somebody to wield Mjolnir
and take on that mantle however he did
not think Jane could do it because she
had breast cancer and was very sick but
of course she already secretly picked up
the hammer and had the mantle of Thor
the whole time so perhaps we could see
somewhat of this in Thor love and
thunder Thor has already kind of given
up the mantle of king of Asgard he gave
it to Valkyrie and it's clear that meal
near somehow comes back into the
equation it somehow gets to the main
timeline so perhaps Thor will go looking
for somebody worthy enough to lift me
linear and he thinks of Jane Foster and
it's very clear from Avengers in game
that Thor definitely still thinks of
Jane Foster but perhaps when he finds
her she may have breast cancer and this
could be something caused by the ether
we know the ether was inside of her and
was slowly killing her when it was after
all it's an infinity stone and it's
insanely powerful so perhaps this could
be a result of the ether that was inside
of her and Thor to the dark world the
storyline remains to be seen but as of
right now it looks like Taika Waititi is
going to put in the breast cancer
element of Jane Foster story of course
change like you said but we'll have to
wait and see but let me know would you
like to see this storyline in the movie
do you think that it would be nice to
have this very strong emotional aspect
connected to Jane Foster
after all Thor had a very emotional
aspect to his storyline and Avengers in
game it would make sense that it would
kind of carry over into Thor love and
thunder as well so let me know all your
thoughts in the comments down below and
let me know how excited you are for Thor
love and thunder give the video a like
if you enjoyed it and don't forget to
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date with all things relating to
the MCU and so you can enter my giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4
new giveaway starting on Twitter and
Instagram very soon so don't forget to
follow me on there and as always thank
you all so much for watching woof woof